DEFINITELY NEED IS
PSYCHOLOGICAL HELP.
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES
REPRESENTS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS SO MUCH
FOR COMING ON.
THIS IS NOT YOUR COMMITTEE
WHERE THE IMPEACHMENT DRAMA
STARTED.
THIS IS JUDICIARY.
BUT YOU WERE THERE TODAY.
WHAT WAS THIS ABOUT?
WHAT DID IT ACCOMPLISH?
WHAT WAS THE POINT.
>> I THINK YOU CAN JUST KEEP
GOING FOR THE REST OF THE
SHOW JUST LIKE YOU ARE
DOING.
I AM ENJOYING WATCHING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I DIDN'T KNOW.
>> Tucker: TOO EASY.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THAT
CLIP FROM THE LADY IN 2006.
THIS IS TOTALLY NUTS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M
WATCHING.
I MEAN, I WALKED IN THERE
TODAY.
FIRST OF ALL, YOU HAVE TO
ASK YOURSELF WHAT THE HELL
ARE THOSE PEOPLE DOING
THERE?
>> Tucker: YEAH.
>> THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
EVIDENCE.
WE ARE HERE TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT.
WHAT YOU SHOULD BE PUTTING
EVIDENCE ON THE TABLE FOR
WHAT THE PRESIDENT DID
WRONG.
AND WHEN THEY WERE ASKED
DIRECT QUESTIONS DO ANY OF
YOU HAVE EVIDENCE, ANY
EVIDENCE THAT'S IN ADAM
SCHIFF'S REPORT TO IMPEACH
THE PRESIDENT ON?
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY.
SO YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF,
WHAT THE HELL IS GOING ON?
>> Tucker: YEAH.
I THINK THEY THINK IT'S
APPEALING TO VOTERS OR
SOMETHING.
I THINK MOST VOTERS, EVEN
MOST DEMOCRATS DESPISE THE
ACADEMIC LEFT.
THE ACADEMIC LEFT IS
DISGUSTING.
AND EVERYONE KIND OF FEELS
THAT WAY.
>> YEAH.
AND THESE -- IF YOU LOOK AT
JUST -- I DON'T KNOW HOW
ANYBODY COULD EVEN WATCH
THIS TODAY.
AND I'M NOT SURE IF ANYBODY
DID WATCH THIS.
I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT THE
RATINGS ARE GOING TO BE
LIKE.
I GUESS WE WILL KNOW IN THE
NEXT COUPLE OF DAYS.
CAN YOU IMAGINE PEOPLE
SITTING THROUGH THAT THAT
ARE HOME WATCHING?
I JUST CAN'T IMAGINE ANYBODY
IS WATCHING.
>> Tucker: I KNOW YOU HAVE
TALKED ABOUT THIS.
BUT THE NEW CHAIRMAN OF YOUR
HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE,
SOMEHOW PULLED THE PHONE
RECORDS OF THE PRESIDENT'S
LAWYERS.
NOW WE ARE GOING TO ASSESS
WITH AN ATTORNEY IN A SECOND
WHETHER THAT WAS EVEN LEGAL.
>> UM-HUH.
>> Tucker: MY QUESTION TO
YOU IS HOW DID HE DO THAT
AND WHAT PRETEXT?
HOW DID THIS HAPPEN?
>> HE HAS SUBPOENA POWER.
SO WHEN THE DEMOCRATS GAIN
CONTROL, THEY HAVE SUBPOENA
POWER.
WE KNEW HE HAD ISSUED.
HE NOTIFIED US THAT HE HAD
SUBPOENAED SOME PHONE
NUMBERS.
WE DIDN'T KNOW WHO THOSE
NUMBERS WERE.
AND, OF COURSE, BECAUSE IT'S
IN THE SCIF AND IT'S
CLASSIFIED, WE CAN'T TALK
ABOUT IT.
>> Tucker: I'M SORRY TO
INTERRUPT.
A SUBPOENA FROM WHOM?
>> HE SUBPOENAED FROM TAT
PHONE RECORDS.
>> Tucker: WHY COULD AT&T
GIVE THIS UP?
>> THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
>> Tucker: WHY WOULDN'T TAT
SAY BUZZ OFF TAKE IT TO
COURT.
>> AT&T SHOULD HAVE WENT TO
COURT TO SEE IF THEY WERE
GOING TO DO WAS THE RIGHT
THING.
>> Tucker: COULD THEY DO
THAT FOR MY PHONE RECORDS
AND YOUR PHONE RECORDS?
>> IT APPEARS LIKE THEY
COULD.
IF ADAM SCHIFF NOW WANTS TO
GO OUT AND SUBPOENA.
THEY HAVE NOW SET A
PRECEDENT WHERE ADAM SCHIFF
CAN GO GET ANY PHONE NUMBER
HE HAS TO AT&T AND AT&T IS
GOING TO COMPLY.
>> Tucker: KEY GET MY EMAIL,
TOO?
>> I DON'T THINK THAT'S BEEN
TRIED.
BE CAREFUL WHAT YOU WISH FOR
HE COULD TRY IT.
THEN EVEN WORSE.
>> Tucker: IS THERE A LIMIT?
YOU RAN THE COMMITTEE.
YOU ARE UNIQUELY QUALIFIED
TO ANSWER THIS OPINION.
IS THERE A LIMIT TO HIS
POWER.
>> I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY
PREVIOUS TIME WE HAVE
SUBPOENAED PHONE NUMBERS ON
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE.
MAYBE BEFORE MY TIME THEY
DID BUT I FIND IT VERY
STRANGE.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT HE DID
THEN, IT'S NOT JUST THE
PRESIDENT'S PHONE RECORDS,
OKAY, OR THE PRESIDENT'S
LAWYER'S PHONE RECORDS, HE
ALSO WAS ABLE TO GET A
JOURNALIST, A JOURNALIST
NOW.
>> Tucker: JOHN SOLOMON.
>> WHO THEY HATE WHO THEY
SAY IS A CONSPIRACY THIRST.
HE WAS ABLE TO FIGURE OUT
THAT WAS JOHN SOLOMON'S
PHONE NUMBER.
SO NOW YOU HAVE A JOURNALIST
INVOLVED.
THEN HE WAS ABLE TO GET MY
NUMBER, RIGHT?
AND BECAUSE I HAD TALKED TO
RUDY GIULIANI AND SOMEHOW
THAT'S NOW A CRIME, AND THEN
I MAKE IT INTO HIS REPORT.
AND WE HAVE TO REMEMBER, I
JUST WANT TO BACK EVERYBODY
UP.
WE SPENT THE LAST THREE
YEARS AT FIRST IF ANY
REPUBLICAN EVER TALKED TO
ANY RUSSIAN AT ANY TIME,
EVEN IF YOU ARE
RUSSIAN-AMERICAN, THAT WAS A
NO-NO.
THEN WE WERE CRITICIZED.
WE SWITCHED TO UKRAINE.
IF YOU TALK TO ANY UKRAINIAN
THAT'S NOW A CRIME.
NOW I CAN'T EVEN TALK TO
RUDY GIULIANI WHO I HAVE
KNOWN FOR 10 YEARS.
THAT'S SUPPOSEDLY A CRIME.
AND I'M IN HIS REPORT FOR
SUPPOSEDLY DOING SOMETHING
WRONG.
SO THIS IS -- THIS IS WRONG.
AND WHAT IS
HAPPENING-WHATEVER IS
HAPPENING IN THIS TOWN IS
WRONG.
I'M GOING TO LOOK AT
WHATEVER LEGAL REMEDIES I
HAVE.
BECAUSE I ACTUALLY HAVE SOME
CIVIL RIGHTS HERE TOO.
CIVIL LIBERTIES.
>> Tucker: IF THEY CAN DO IT
TO YOU, THEN WHAT PROTECTION
DO WE HAVE?
>> THEY CAN DO IT TO YOU.
>> Tucker: ALREADY CALLED ME